we simplify problem yeah I'm not going
to um for the two reasons number one I
don't think everything happened up for a
series yet
remember I've only got two terms here I
want the third one and then I can say
business unit I mean I know it's not but
this could still be this crystal Forman
a pain at the moment occurred but after
the next one he will be excluded that
possibility
so now I'm gonna say a three now please
mom
the question is not asked for an A three
right it's gonna ask for an A in I've
got to get to like a 300 ml 300 ml and
then everything's gonna cancel out okay
yeah now I need to establish the patent
right so again I'm going there it's that
previous enough it gets its interest
apply and then okay does that make sense
so you can see here I'm gonna take
everything you gonna add that one puts
reserve fire so I'm getting this one of
the Handy ways that this helps us here
and not factorizing sort of makes it
obvious is that when I write it like
this it is painfully obvious that
that there are literally like what is a
three what's the definition of a three
again about going off to the third
repayment look one two three there are
the three repayments right you can
actually see them there now I've done
enough now that I actually do want to
actually act dries out so I can see the
series that is forming charitable
obviously so this is still a three that
I'm working with okay this guy's a fraud
you can see is not really part of this
series it's just kind of sitting out
what he's already growing and growing
and growing so I'm just gonna invite him
there
note that his power is exactly the same
as the number of months that were going
and what factor would you like me to
take out of this yeah yeah I think it
would be good I'm gonna get one better
than that and I'm gonna take out - okay
because I've got a whole screen of
negatives here and if I take out a minus
sign that would deal with all of them
okay at the same time not anything and
I'm going to take out a common factor
I'm also going to write this series in
Reverse one yes
Plus this why do you do that most people
I mean I don't you can see it's a
progression either way but most of us
have brains feel that like whenever when
a GP is there and it's growing it is
more obvious the GP and you can make
sure you get the right number of turn to
know if the ratio is or that kind of
okay now why did I see step I wanted a
pattern once it okay because now off of
this I can write and okay I've got one
about two of the three now ready
generalized right clearly you've got
that 300cc brand restarted right and
he's going to have some number of
interest calculations attitude and you
can see that it's gonna be in because I
match up three with three and two with
two and one with one right you see how
important the patent is and off-by-one
errors are the most common mistake to
make it a question like this okay so up
there that's way it employs I'll go mine
take my hand out the front and then
here's my series of all of the
repayments right never remember how I
said hey look remember how I said a one
has one repetitive but a two has one too
repetitive and lost the m3 has the one
two three easy payments right does that
make sense so how many terms are there
to be in this series as it grows the
answers there should be in of them every
payments right so therefore it's gonna
have this first future
and it's going to end on the end of term
which is and minus one that's the actual
power right
because really what you've got there is
a 0 then 1 2 3 4 up to here and turns
into right now at this point this here I
can say oh this is a GP that I can do
something with right and to make it
really obvious I'm going to say a piece
is a GP where now every GP now you need
to take back to Sameer theory and free
GP is defined by 3 and only 3 features
would you be lettuce you know what they
are hey wait post post what ain't what
what is that first term which is 1 ok
the next piece of the patient is which
is the common ratio which is and then at
this point rather than say N equals
something because I'm gonna say any was
in I'm just gonna say the number of
turns around in terms okay so I've
identified all the pieces of my
geometric progression now okay this is
equal to first guy hanging out the front
make sure you get the right number of
zeros and then in here I get sausage in
the psalm of a j-pin it's been a while
since we've done something keeping
excuse me there are two different forms
right one which is looking like this and
the other one with a numerator
denominator of around over that which
one would you prefer in this question
the second one wait a second
yeah the ratio is a bigger number it's a
thing that's growing yeah so I just
choose the foam that doesn't give me a
double menu okay
so I'm going to choose this one don't
skip out right isn't a there I know it's
one but just as many cases especially in
the harder questions I mean this is
question 15 this is the second last one
but a is sometimes about one and you
don't want to just ignore it that's a
very distinctive okay so I'm going to go
first ten times the common ratio to the
power of however many terms there are to
take away one all over a common ratio
again particular one babe
all right lovely so much what am i doing
this thing what's the point of having a
general progression of general
expression for the progression of all of
these potatoes okay I'm headed towards
the monthly repayment and I can
certainly say something a month in Perry
would I have the whole series in view
how many terms are they in the whole
series
there should be 300 right I was right
I want a 300 the amount of striking at
303 payment by one to gbi1 through the
ER that began Betty pay off right I'm
sorry
it's gonna be an unhappy man so
therefore and I'll give you a second to
catch up with me or it heads out of me I
don't know if this face here I want this
out of this right now I'm so lean for
what am i solving for there's only one
credit left I am and and where to go
there it is em that's the actual thing
and they give me a number right once you
put a 300 Fiat and here and this means
0m Selassie left okay I have a shotgun
that you calculate a buck way